C-3PO, le personnage de Monopoly et Pikachu.
Y a au moins l'un de ces trois exemples sur lequel rien ne vous choque ?
Eh bien vous avez tort.
Et vous pouvez le vérifier vous-même.
C-3PO a une jambe en argent.
Monsieur Monopoly n'a jamais eu de monocle.
Et Pikachu n'a jamais eu de queue noire.
Alors quoi ? Vos souvenirs vous ont joué des tours ?
Enfin même pas vos souvenirs.
Mais nos souvenirs
de manière collective.
Est-ce qu'il est possible qu'on se soit tous souvenu de quelque chose
de faux au point où c'est presque comme si
on avait été, à un moment, dans une
une autre réalité ?
*intro*
En 2010 Fiona Broome
une américaine
découvre un phénomène étrange.
Pendant une conférence, elle se rend compte
que la plupart des participants croyaient comme elle, que Nelson Mandela
était mort durant son emprisonnement en 1980.
Alors qu'il mourra bien plus tard, en 2013.
Elle en fait un nom, "l'Effet Mandela".
Et elle se rend compte que cela touche d'autres histoires
Comme le fait qu'on pense que le héros de la place Tian'anmen se serait fait écraser par le tank
suite à son opposition
ou que Mère Teresa se serait faite canoniser dans les années 90 alors que
cela s'est passé en 2016.
Une confusion de la mémoire collective, quand nous sommes tous convaincus de partager un souvenir en commun
alors qu'il n'existe pas ou qu'il est déformé.
Alors ça peut faire sourire dit comme ça mais il faut se dire que bon nombre de personnes
qui soutiennent ces faits faussés pensent détenir la vérité,
ils pensent carrément que c'est une déformation de la réalité
dont on est tous victimes avec des souvenirs alternatifs causés par l'existence de deux réalités
à un moment donné, dans une seule réalité.
Deux réalités superposées, ça vous dit quelque chose ? Le chat de Schrödinger.
Et si vous n'êtes pas sûr de ce que c'est, je vous conseille de regarder cette vidéo lorsque vous aurez fini celle-ci.
C'est ce chat qui est à la fois mort, et à la fois vivant. Les deux états superposés.
Pour Hugh Everett, physicien américain, il y a alors deux mondes parallèles :
l'un ou le chat est vivant et l'autre où il est mort.
Chaque événement que nous rencontrons, à n'importe quelle échelle, ne connaît pas un seul résultat
mais une bifurcation entre deux ou plusieurs résultats possibles
et les réalités altérées par les autres résultats vivraient alors en parallèle de la notre.
Et il faut pas imaginer que ces mondes parallèles qui surgissent soient de la substance, de la nouvelle matière
mais ce sont plutôt des nouvelles structures.
Mais, est-ce que tout ça est vraiment lié au fait que Dark Vador n'a jamais prononcé la phrase
"Luke, je suis ton père" ?
Mais :
Que le mot "Ewok" n'est jamais mentionné dans un film Star Wars ?
Qu'Onix ne s'écrive pas O-N-Y-X mais bien O-N-I-X ?
Ou que les Libyens, de Retour vers le futur, ne conduisent pas ce type de véhicule
mais un van Volkswagen ?
Pas vraiment !
Notre cerveau n'est pas une machine infaillible,
capable de mémoriser de manière intacte toutes les informations.
Certains souvenirs se transforment ou s'effacent avec le temps
et c'est normal.
Mais surtout, nos représentations mentales peuvent être remises en question
sous l'effet de groupe.
Combien de fois vous est-il arrivé, vous comme moi, de remettre en question vos certitudes
lorsque 3, 4, 5 personnes soutiennent fermement le contraire ?
Il y a aussi un phénomène de dissonance cognitive
qui peut s'observer parfois.
Ca nous arrive de nous retrouver dans un état très désagréable
lorsque quelqu'un confronte une information incompatible avec nos croyances.
On va souvent choisir de renforcer nos croyances
et ne pas laisser place à la critique.
Mais ces troubles de la mémoire ne concernent pas que des éléments culturels.
Ces faux souvenirs peuvent avoir des conséquences beaucoup plus graves chez l'être humain.
Steve Titus est un américain de 31 ans
qui rentrait, un soir, du restaurant en compagnie de sa jeune épouse
quand une voiture de police les arrêta sur la route.
La voiture de Titus ressemblait un peu à la voiture d'un agresseur sexuel
qui avait violé une auto-stoppeuse un peu plus tôt dans la journée.
Et pas de chance pour lui, Titus ressemblait également un peu à cet homme.
Les policiers l'ont pris en photo, mis le cliché au milieu de ceux d'autres personnes,
et les ont présentés à la victime.
En voyant le portrait de Titus, la victime a déclaré :
"C'est lui qui ressemble le plus"
Le procès s'ouvre et Titus se retrouve sur le banc des accusés,
face à lui, la victime qui déclare :
"Je suis absolument sûre que c'est cet homme"
Titus est alors jugé coupable et envoyé directement en prison.
Evidemment, il n'a cessé de dire en vain qu'il était innocent,
il a supplié les juges de le libérer
sans grand succès.
Il a néanmoins pu raconter son histoire à un journaliste d'investigation
qui a pu mener une enquête et trouver le vrai coupable
déjà soupçonné d'une cinquantaine de viols.
Le véritable agresseur est alors emprisonné et Titus est libéré.
L'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là,
laissant au mieux un gros traumatisme à Titus
mais malheureusement, l'homme fut considérablement marqué par cette affaire
qui lui a fait perdre son travail et l'intégralité de ses économies.
Il a porté plainte contre la police pour obtenir justice
mais à quelques jours du procès, il s'est réveillé plié en deux par la douleur
et a subi une crise cardiaque mortelle, liée au stress.
Et ce n'est pas un cas isolé.
Dans le cadre d'un projet aux Etats-Unis, une étude a été menée
sur le cas de 300 prisonniers à tort qui ont effectué 5, 10, 20 ans de prison
pour des crimes qu'ils n'avaient pas commis.
Des tests ADN ayant prouvé qu'ils étaient biens innocents.
3/4 des 300 innocents condamnés l'ont été à cause d'une mémoire défaillante des témoins oculaires.
A cause d'un faux souvenir.
Mais le cas de Titus a servi.
Il y a une psychologue cognitive américaine, spécialisée dans la mémoire humaine
qui a pu travailler dessus.
C'est Elizabeth Loftus.
Son objectif est de comprendre pourquoi notre cerveau retient des souvenirs faussés.
Selon elle, notre mémoire n'enregistre pas tout comme un magnétoscope
mais fonctionne plutôt comme une page Wikipédia.
On peut changer les informations qui la composent.
Mais les autres le peuvent aussi.
On appelle ça la mémoire constructive
Elle a mis en place plusieurs études pour démontrer ce phénomène.
Dans l'une d'entre elles, une simulation d'accident de route a été montrée à des gens.
Il y a un 1er groupe qui devait répondre à la question :
"A quelle vitesse allaient les voitures lors de l'impact ?"
Et un 2nd groupe à la question:
"A quelle vitesse allaient les voitures lors du choc ?"
Et bien, les gens du 2nd groupe trouvaient que les voitures allaient plus vite
parce que le mot "choc" avait construit un souvenir plus violent dans leur mémoire.
Il y en a même certains qui parlaient de morceaux de verre sur le lieu de l'accident
alors qu'il n'y en a jamais eu.
Leur mémoire a été formatée par l'angle des questions posées
et des mots employés.
Une autre étude mise en place par l'équipe d'Elizabeth concerne les militaires.
Des soldats ont été interrogés de manière agressive et physiquement violente
pendant 30 minutes.
A la fin de l'interrogatoire, ils devaient identifier la personne
qui venait de leur faire passer un mauvais quart d'heure
enfin deux mauvais quarts d'heure du coup parce que c'est 30 minutes.
Lors de leur réflexion, on leur donnait des suggestions
qui insinuaient que c'était une personne différente de celle qu'ils s'apprêtaient à choisir.
Il y a beaucoup de cobayes qui choisissaient alors la mauvaise personne
en prenant même parfois un interrogateur totalement différent.
Donc on associant de fausses informations sur des expériences que des gens ont vécues
on peut déformer et changer leurs souvenirs.
Elizabeth ne s'est pas arrêtée là.
Elle a dénoncé pas mal de psychothérapeutes qui utilisaient un procédé de ce type là
pour soigner leurs patients.
Pour les aider, par exemple, à surpasser un traumatisme,
ils leurs implantaient des faux souvenirs, parfois encore plus difficiles à assumer,
histoire de les délivrer de leurs problèmes de base.
On observait du coup des cas de patients qui sortaient de thérapie avec un problème
différent de celui avec lequel ils étaient entrés.
Mais elle ne condamne pas la mémoire constructive comme un phénomène purement néfaste.
Même si de fortes questions éthiques se posent, tout dépend, pour elle,
des souvenirs que l'on souhaite moduler et dans quel but.
Je vous laisse vous faire votre propre opinion là-dessus.
J'espère que l'effet Mandela est maintenant clair pour vous,
qu'il ne vous a pas trop traumatisé.
Parce que c'est quand même dingue de réaliser d'un coup que l'image
qu'on se fait d'un souvenir ou de quelqu'un ou d'une chose
puisse être totalement différente, comme ça, d'une seconde à l'autre.
N'hésitez pas à partager vos effets Mandela dans les commentaires.
La plupart des exemples disponibles sur Internet sont américains.
Ce serait cool de voir des exemples directement liés à la culture française.
Si ce n'est pas déjà fait, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
pour ne pas rater les futures vidéos,
il y en a au moins une par semaine donc c'est cool.
Merci à tous ceux qui contribuent sur le Tipee
C'est grâce à vous que j'ai pu avoir des lumières trop cool
qui donnent une telle qualité d'image donc merci beaucoup.
Je vous envoie du love et de la peace.
Ciao !